Let's say I have two different gas
at two different temperatures,
which are exactly in contact with one another.
This is my cyclazed gas.
Here, let me draw some of the molecules of cyclase gas.
And this system here,
as you call it,
has just come into contact with this blue gas.
This blue gas here.
And let's say just when we start our simulation, our experiment,
this cyclazed gas has a higher temperature.
Higher temperature.
And our blue gas has a lower temperature.
Lower temperature.
Let us recall what is the temperature,
especially if we think of it on a molecular scale.
Higher temperature, lower temperature.
The temperature is proportional to the average kinetic energy.
These molecules will vibrate, circle around.
They will have -
each of them will have kinetic energy
and if you average them
this will be proportional to the temperature.
Let me depict the kinetic energy of each of these separate molecules.
Perhaps this is what he is doing.
Maybe this goes in that direction.
This goes in that direction.
And so,
note, they all have different directions.
And the magnitude of their speed may be different.
They all have different speeds.
They can all have different speeds.
They have different speeds.
And they hit each other.
They transfer their kinetic energy,
transfer their impulse
from one particle to another.
But when we talk about temperature,
we are talking about the average kinetic energy
or which is proportional to
the average kinetic energy of the system.
Each of these molecules will have some kinetic energy.
But on average it will be lower.
Perhaps this one is doing something like that.
He does that.
They are different,
but on average they will have less energy.
I hope you can see these cyclamen arrows
are larger than these blue arrows,
which I paint.
And it does not have to be all -
for example, this can have a lot of kinetic energy.
But when you average everything,
the average here will be lower than the average here.
Like this.
If this is our initial condition,
what do we think will happen?
Before our various gas groups
struggled with themselves
or the cyclamate molecules bumped with cyclamen.
The blues hit the blue.
But now they will start shuffling with each other.
And you can imagine that when this molecule here
collide with this molecule,
it will transfer some kinetic energy to it.
After the collision, this can move.
After the collision -
let's say that they just collided.
It's just before
and let's say they just stopped being pushed into each other.
Just after they have finished hitting each other,
this can ricochet.
This will go this way.
Let me do this in a different color.
He can hit this, bounce
and then transfer some of its kinetic energy
and then jump in that direction.
While this, after the collision,
it may be moving much faster in that direction.
And notice, you have a transfer of energy.
Exactly with this collision you have a kinetic energy transfer
of this molecule to this molecule.
And it will happen in the system.
Faster molecules, those with higher kinetic energy -
while they collide, you will have an energy transfer.
You will have a transfer of energy from a higher temperature
to a lower temperature.
Power transfer.
This is a transfer of energy.
And you can accept this for the transfer of heat -
here we talk about temperature.
Things that are related to temperature,
we will call it "thermal".
This is a heat transfer.
Transfer of heat.
If you start with higher energy here,
you will have a higher average kinetic energy.
Here you will have lower average kinetic energy.
But it will transfer energy from the cyclamen to the blue.
This will go from a higher temperature
to a lower temperature.
And this energy, which is transferred,
we call - and this is a word you probably hear many times -
this energy that is transferred is called "heat".
Literally, this warmer gas here heats this cooler gas.
And the way this heat transfer takes place,
when it is through a collision of particles,
the transfer of kinetic energy to the collision of particles,
who transfer the impulse,
we call conducting.
We call this heat (heat).
Or just conducting.
Let me record a "thermal performance".
I'll do it in a new color.
What I describe is a thermal conduction.
Which, in a certain way, you feel many times -
transfer of heat.
For example, you probably know the feeling,
if you take, I do not know if you take a saucepan.
Let's say you pick up such a saucepan.
Let's say there is a cold pot in the beginning.
That is, the particles in the pot have lower kinetic energy.
I will not be able to draw all of them.
And then put it on fire.
Put it on fire.
Let's see if I can draw this.
It's a fire.
And we talk about heating the metal on the pan,
I'm not dealing with what's inside the pan right now.
This fire will first heat the bottom of this saucepan.
And it will do so mainly by thermal conduction,
because the fire is just super hot air particles
and these super hot air particles
will hit the metal particles of your pan.
These metal particles of this saucepan -
their kinetic energy will begin to rise.
This part of the pot will start to heat up.
Just when you turn on your stove,
the top of this saucepan may still be cold,
but the bottom will quickly become very hot.
But if you just wait a few minutes,
these metal particles will continue to be pushed
and vibrate to each other.
And eventually, this upper part here
it will be quite hot.
It'll be pretty hot.
And the way the top of this metal has become hot,
is by heat conduction -
first the metal on the bottom has become hot,
then these particles have collided with their neighbors
or have vibrated to their neighbors
and have transferred some of this kinetic energy.
And you see this heat transfer again
from a higher temperature area
to an area with a cooler or lower temperature.